[Music]
and desperate times news I know Oh God
the Spanish I know I know I know because
I eat a delicious unnie kitty from I
know huh submitted by grammar nazi' a
rule words I hate that word rule it's
rule a rule Italian town is offering
people ten thousand dollars to move here
because it's gonna die the price sucks
then I wouldn't do that that means
you're telling people come here but then
the people that would take ten thousand
to move there really really need it and
do you really want crackheads in your
neighborhood I wouldn't have them move
in and then when I know they have ten
thousand problems so you're gonna give
up ten thousand and then you're gonna
take goes back in the economy and now
you have a homeless crackhead sitting on
your street and you brought them there
is it a coastal Italian place so there's
a lot of these villages across Italy
that they they have like an aging
population their schools are on the
verge of being shut down because there's
not enough kid there oh no they're
selling homes for just like a little bit
over a dollar well just so they can have
people move in like there they need
people and these are like in rural areas
did you know this is happening globally
do we need a move Jane is there
something you know that's gonna Italy
this is happening globally like even in
our American States mm-hmm the
population is all moving to metropolitan
yeah yeah I mean same with Japan there's
like abandoned towns ghost towns for me
all that [ __ ] that's just happening girl
that's just all over the world movie
value you know why is cuz people think
that being close to technology is it's
the [ __ ] it's the job it's not man we
have so much traffic it's because of
like they don't have jobs yeah so these
places now they're just trying to like
entice people to move Josh your
homestead in Italy they're asking for
people to you know that for them to
commit at least three years and that's
when they'll get the $10,000 all smart
you know money for so they really want
people that have kids to movie-like fam
yeah but then they'll also pay if you
have babies when you live there and then
they'll also pay more if you start a
business and one of those many abandoned
businesses that they have it'd be cool
for like people who just want to just
like run away from here and start over
you know like I just feel like my life
is out there let them all be together I
didn't take I want to come back all good
cuz the hard part about this is that's
very enticing for someone like myself
who is 50 or something I'm not if I'm
saying like 50 or 60 years yeah
then I would want to go $10,000 for me
I'm gonna retire anyways I don't want
anybody to talk that's fifty that's when
you make the most money really yeah
but yes you they don't really want that
yeah they want families they want the
schools to be used they want to like
have a flourishing that's the hard part
to because a lot of parents are looking
for good schools so if the schools are
shutting down not doing too good there's
no incentive for mojo you can start your
country in another country Dahlia Tamale
an Italian bring in the teachers you
bring in the people to my Filipinos you
know what man you get paid they're
familiar with my type a little bit cuz
they have the Mafia the Lestrade not
strapped and then they have Joe Mallya
so they would be okay with the culture
you know I'd be down with that Somali
just tell ya yeah I like French food
French food Italian food Elliot I feel
like in when we were in France and Eva
when we were there
I feel like this because like
TripAdvisor and Yelp isn't prevalent
there we needed to know a local so the
spot that I went to that was the best
was the place that Mario's co-worker
who's a foods from France told us to go
to and that was the best place that we
everywhere else we go in TripAdvisor
whatever [ __ ] trash all the Michelin
was [ __ ] I was so upset dude I went into
Michelin I guess like in those type to
play even like Japan like the best
places that I've had there were just
random spots that I walked into but
nobody's yelping these spots you know a
lot of those places too because it's
like mainly for look for local people
they have to always call ahead and make
a razor
because we just pop up they'll be like
where's your reservation yeah like I
didn't know that because I learned from
my cousin lives there too him and her
boyfriend with reservations in Flast
yeah yeah see that's like this [ __ ] that
we don't know about so it's kind of hard
in those type of country I feel like in
France from what I've seen on like shows
like this places they went to I mean I
just see these places where the [ __ ]
were they we went to trash our [ __ ]
tourist traps oh that was sad yeah man I
like the Italian food and Japanese food
and friends better than French food I
don't ever want to get into another uber
in France ever be Oh is on feel they're
like dizzy machine tacos nasty feels
like you're in the bumper cars at the
[ __ ] that's a fair this is Mel like
Drakkar Noir the [ __ ] cry no i heavy ass
spice Old Spice Cologne and B oh thanks
onions like don't being chopped and they
don't put the windows down no I mean
they don't put the windows yeah up like
it's all good it's all down there's no
AC and then the seat is cloth so it's
like holding into like there's a lot of
smoke surprisingly I thought la had smog
and the whole place smells like exhaust
smoke cigarettes Eliza would you like to
be a hot box to see my like When in Rome
you know like when I'm out there I'm
like oh my god this is [ __ ] French
France cigarettes that's [ __ ] pipe
this guys smoking a cigarette oh my God
look at that guy this French dudes
pissing on the street that's [ __ ]
brats now I'm a always [ __ ] fat as
[ __ ] everything hurt my kneecaps my
[ __ ] feet I was fat too and I felt
the same thing you were not there but I
was feeling this area no but you know
what it's like right
the swollen ankles and [ __ ] and you're
hot all the [ __ ] time I had to
experience that doing it it [ __ ] suck
if I went back to France now I bet you'd
be 10 times more enjoyable go to Italy
dude you love it oh so they're saying
that now 139 villages have fewer than
150 residents and that like for this one
village but they did you say there were
racist oh there was a race
I say to you so like no they gots I wish
she was an Italian yeah they were kind
of like oh she's an American no so I
went with Casey and then aka Indiana
right and so Deanna's Filipino and then
a cave looks like a white guy or he
could look Italian does it mean you tell
you know oh yeah he's passed you passed
polish habit lol I forgot
yeah that's the reason why we went to
the bridge a we got so then we would go
to like there was one time when we both
walked in to a store like a liquor store
whatever and then they were being super
nice like talking to Italian us but
we're like trying to figure it out and
then here like behind us that's one aka
I mean Casey Indiana come in and then
they completely change your demeanor
like crazy but this was in this is in
Venice when they were in like the suburb
event it's not in the mean they got mean
towards Kasey and Vienna no they got
mean towards me and a cake cuz then we
started talking English to them and then
I guess they realized that you're
American yeah that we're American and
they just kind of like change like their
whole demeanor yeah that's why your
[ __ ] store is gonna disappear you
done it [ __ ]
that's this best of dumping like if you
have a place that has commodity and
goods that clearly isn't a tourist area
what the [ __ ] were you expecting you
know this is a suburb so I don't know if
they get a lot of tourists I'm pretty
sure maybe especially like countries
like that in those areas like tourism is
a huge part of their [ __ ] money you
know so it doesn't makes it like I
understand it figured you got a trash
we're just coming in and you guys
connect Lea communicate with them like
what's the [ __ ] problem like I would
never do that that's not very smart
I don't experience any of that me
neither not even a sliver of it were you
guys in Maine you just have to go
through suburbs like there's a rest
stops and suburbs that this has to stop
in yeah but there was this uh be me and
long-haired Casey we look late in the
shower for four weeks here's a recent
carrot yeah I dated that Casey for like
two months
wow really yeah so it's like clean-cut
Casey mm-hmm
I want to try the food I'm not saying
that the entire country was like that
because we did good so I'm just talking
about that store
Annie we went to many cities and that
that was the only time that we
like the most but it was a beautiful
case and everyone's nice yeah do they
speak English no because in in France
everyone spoke English but some people
pretended like they did it yeah then I'm
all like I don't know you do
[ __ ]
we didn't get any English don't don't
try it I mean like in Italy the place
we've been to don't you could tell that
they're trying really hard but he could
also tell they just don't it was a fruit
stand person at the place that we were
staying on in France that was [ __ ]
hello rude to Muriel why don't only one
person though so that was majority the
people are really nice but there was one
[ __ ] that was hella [ __ ] mean to her
dude and some other French people out of
be like that guy's [ __ ] mean she was
just asking how much the fruits were
he's just like like [ __ ] rolling his
eyes and [ __ ] a little bug yeah
obviously some nice fresh people were
like he's just need to worry about it ah
you know you know what I like is the
French waiters attitude problems cuz
they remind me of like Cantonese waiters
like they would [ __ ] I don't know
they're just kind of like joking but
then like I think in American culture it
would kind of be like dude you're being
unprofessional and you're being kind of
rude but like like Dobby smart-alecky is
what it is like I remember it was like
oh we're ready to pay and then he goes
oh everybody here like everyone's gonna
be paid for it and I was like no no no
no and then I don't know but then the
way he did it was kind of like smart
aleck funny so there was a cafe that we
went to that we just got brechler
croissants and whatever in the morning
right and then she got eggs and then she
was like do you have ketchup at the
[ __ ] waiter goes Jay Chou and he gets
his menu starts tapping head no no no no
no no what do you get for ketchup though
but he was jolly like yeah that's a kind
of so don't what little village is this
what was a lot of them tortellini
tortellini I can try if you want it's
for Gomez Valley I think next to any big
cities that we might know like Florence
or well yeah so because there's like so
many of these like they're just
scattered through the whole country
oh well let me show you some photos so
you oh that's beautiful that's one
little village yeah we drove by a bunch
of
I know it's awesome even in Germany - I
want to live one of these and like wait
by the window like my lover left out to
see and I'm waiting for him to come back
why are you just like milking the cow
whether you come in the bed he's rich in
her and her fancy shoes for it she's
rich she's not doing Italian touches
yeah I sent letters out to my lover out
at sea and I'm waiting for him to come
home
oh machines no Christopher Columbus in
my new world like I might be able to
live somewhere like that if there's
really good fast internet connection and
there's one [ __ ] Muay Thai gym like
you might be able to survive because
then I would just train my ass every
[ __ ] day go to sleep you know what I
do whatever work I can wake up in the
morning [ __ ] watch the internet and
then [ __ ] Moy titrating get more time
for a year only do it you bet there's
gonna be hiking you can farm probably
great farm dude it's gonna be dope man I
want to do ready I want to do that
already right now and I'm trying to get
you guys on board if I had crazy
I could stream there that's what I'm
saying they won't even be like leaving
Los Angeles I always told my Bears like
I would totally moved to Missouri if you
guys had Internet Korea is a very good
we were uploading [ __ ] and I couldn't
even believe it Cory has a number wife
for an Internet everywhere and all these
countries that like specifically Korea
they can actually it's like that
fiber-optic stuff right so because it's
like a newer area they could [ __ ]
there's no old infrastructure they have
to break through to do all that [ __ ] so
that's what I was told is because they
were preparing like in the sixties or
80s or whatever whenever Internet I
think at the 80s 80s they just started
[ __ ] building out the cities ready
for the internet yeah there were like
let's do it okay okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]